so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Batman Beyond and what
I'm hoping is that at the end of this
video
you'll have a strong understanding of
the character as well as why fans are
looking forward to the return of Terry
McGinnis and the post DC rebirth
continuity
so much like Harley Quinn Terry McGinnis
and the Batman Beyond concept debuted as
part of DC's animated universe in 1999
and were created by Bruce Timm Paul Dini
and Alan Burnett during a 2001 interview
with tomorrow's publishing a publisher
of magazines and comics founded in 1994
and specializing in the history of the
comic industry Bruce Timm had stated
that with 1994's batman the animated
series receiving universal acclaim and
considered to be one of the best
animated series ever created and nine to
97 DC have produced a relaunch in the
form of the new Batman adventures to
sidetrack here for those of you who
never saw the original Batman the
Animated Series because the 1987 Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles in 1992 x-men
cartoon shows had reinvigorated interest
in creating animated content based on
comics during the late 20th century DC
sought to capitalize on this trend by
launching Batman the Animated Series
with a show grew to be hugely popular
due to its tone and pacing with Mark
Hamill's Joker becoming more popular
than Batman himself in an interview with
Kevin Smith during episode 7 of fat man
on Batman Bruce Timm had stated that
where the show was most successful among
adults and older teens Warner Brothers
target demographic was actually the six
to 11 year old range looking to the
success that came with introducing Dick
Grayson in 1940 the Warner Brothers
ordered the introduction and consistent
inclusion of Dick Grayson as Robin as
well as a rebranding of the series under
the title The Adventures of Batman and
Robin
where these surface changes saw Warner
Brothers goals achieved temporarily when
the feature film Batman mask of the
phantasm was released the cartoon show
was pushed to higher levels of
popularity now regarding the events
leading up to the release of Batman
Beyond with 1996 seeing the release of
Superman the animated series followed by
the new Batman and Superman adventures
in 1997 at the time Warner Brothers was
beginning to lose interest from the six
to eleven year old demographic yet again
as a result Bruce Timm was contacted to
create a teenage version of Bruce Wayne
who could happen a wonder brother
started age group by making the hero
more relatable as a teenager while Tim
Dini and Burnett were not initially on
board with the idea due to their desire
to keep the continuity the same after
taking the weekend to brainstorm ideas
the trio came up with the idea to
provide a spin-off series which combined
the dystopian future of The Dark Knight
Returns the science-fiction both
which could come together to create a
whole new brand while maintaining the
roots of what made the animated Batman
franchise so great pitching the idea to
the president of Warner Brothers the
concept was immediately accepted and a
blank check was issued allowing Tim Dini
and Burnett to finish out the ten
remaining episodes of Batman and
Superman adventures before canceling the
series and starting work on Batman
Beyond centering on Terry McGinnis
Batman Beyond saw wholesale removal of
most of Bruce Wayne's most prominent
friends enemies and allies with Alfred
Pennyworth Lucius Fox Commissioner James
Gordon
Nightwing Batgirl Catwoman a Tim Drake
either dying of natural causes
abandoning Bruce Wayne or simply moving
on in addition to this the most famous
members of Batman's rogues gallery
including the Joker Harley Quinn penguin
two-face poison ivy and others were
removed as well although no real
information was forthcoming on where
they had gone aside from their presume
incarcerations or deaths then with the
pilot episode established these
principals and Bruce Wayne facing forced
retirement due to his age making him
unable to fight crime adequately this
series jumped forward 20 years to the
life of Terry McGinnis carrying on
Batman's mantle under the watchful eye
of Bruce Wayne taking a page out of the
original Batman cartoon series under
Dini Tim and Burnett a slow rollout of
Terry's life unfolded growing to depict
him living within Gotham which had
become a mega city immersed in crime due
to Bruce's inactivity for the last 20
years as well as groups like The Joker's
gang modeling themselves after the
iconic villain and overpowering police
furthermore because Batman's origin is
something of a household's story the
problem faced by Dini Tim and Burnett
was providing a means for Terry to
undertake the mantle without appearing
to recreate the age-old tale to this end
Terry was shown to have a strained
relationship with his father Warren
McGinnis while harboring a bit of an
antihero streak and a strong sense of
justice encountering Bruce Wayne for the
first time in the series by engaging in
a high-speed chase with the Joker's
after the gang hit arrest Harry and his
girlfriend Dana where Terry and Bruce
fought the gang off together following
this short battle Terry had discovered
the entrance to the Batcave leading him
to realize that Bruce and Batman
were one in the same where the discovery
did earn Terry the I refused who cast
him out of the cave and forbid his
return
Terry steps to undertake the Batman
mantle came when his father had been
killed under the orders of Derek powers
a corrupt businessman who had merged
powers industries with Wayne Enterprises
to form the wayne-powers corporation and
began usurping control of the company in
the face of Bruce's failing health
appealing to Bruce's own experience in
losing his parents Terry took on a more
technologically advanced variant of the
bat suit and after doing battle with
powers who is exposed to a radioactive
chemical in the process powers will not
to become Terry's arch-nemesis while
Terry himself
sought to eliminate the corruption which
had seized control of Gotham now
following this pilot episode and going
into the main series itself Batman
Beyond actually had a bit of a slow
start the reason for this was due to the
fact that prospective viewers were
essentially jumping into an extreme
variant of the Batman character with
Batman the Animated Series the reason
the show saw its massive popularity was
due to the fact that ritually all the
characters contained within were
established and recognizable whether it
be the Joker the penguin two-face
Commissioner Gordon did grace it or even
Bruce himself the television series was
predicated on over 50 years worth of
stories however by casting aside all
established concepts and walking into
something wholly new prospective viewers
were essentially asked to walk away from
everything that had made Batman the
Animated Series so great and try
something new
seeing their gamble pay off as the
Batman Beyond series began to focus on
Terry's relationship with his girlfriend
Dana the strain that came with Terry
living a double life as well as the
various high school problems he
experienced many of the show's viewers
were able to identify and live
vicariously through Terry and being the
next generation of one of DC's most
iconic heroes and the viewers themselves
faced their own high school struggles
and issues with balancing the romantic
lives and personal lives furthermore
because the goal of didi and Tim was to
make Terry's own hero his enemies and
allies kept the roots of the original
Batman villains but were updated for the
new audience with villains like the
shape-shifting ink standing in for
Clayface along with the Royal Flush gang
mr. freeze and Ra's al Ghul returning to
the landscape alongside Barbara Gordon
as a new police commissioner the Batman
Beyond series rutu become nearly as
popular as the original Batman series
and that newer and younger fans now had
a Batman of their own to enjoy and grow
attached to this experience was
bolstered by the fact that with a
Superman animated series continuing to
run strong since its launch DC quite
literally took over the world of
animated adaptations two comic related
content furthermore while
and beyond didn't immediately see a
crossover with the rest of DC's
offerings at the time in season 3
Terry was given his own team up with a
futuristic version of the Justice League
whose popularity was used by Bruce Timm
to initiate the launch of the Justice
League TV show in 2001 now having said
all of that the first comic book
appearance of Terry McGinnis with NBC
came with a six-part miniseries Batman
Beyond released in March of 1999 as a
monthly series of written by Hilary J
Bader the miniseries was more of a comic
book retelling of Terry's first
encounter with the various members of
his rogues gallery including Derek
towers henchman mr. fix Inc Alec Sano
and others with the last issue of the
six-part series ending in September a
second volume was launched in October of
1999 with Hilary Bader returning his
writer running for 24 issues in
continuing to remain a monthly series
unlike the miniseries vol 2 functioned
to expand on the Batman Beyond universe
while remaining isolated from the main
DC continuity in a 2003 interview with
Shannon Muir a sweet 101.com
a website that no longer functions but
previously focused on blog posts
relating to the fledgling geek culture
movement Bader had stated that is
someone best known for being a
contributing writer to Star Trek The
Next Generation Star Trek Voyager in
Deep Space nine while she was familiar
with the issue of deadlines the problems
she faced was that the comics could not
move ahead of the actual series itself
in order to keep this from happening
volume to fat itself suffering from
watches and wanes as son comics were
forced into multiple parts or existing
plot threads were simply left hanging
with the series being cancelled in 2001
now before we go any further is
something that I want to do here is take
a second and talk about Terry's
relationship to Bruce by this point in
the history of DC Comics in the DC
Animated universe is common knowledge
among readers that Terry McGinnis was
the biological son of Bruce Wayne now
the reason I say was is that this idea
was not established until the final
episode of Justice League Unlimited
which was really more of an unofficial
ending than an official ending and
because Bruce had never produced a child
of his own Amanda Waller a fan favorite
character similar to Nick Fury from
Marvel Comics had reasoned that with
Bruce growing older and unable to remain
Batman from
long haul steps we need to be taken to
ensure his legacy continued injecting
Terry's father with a narrow tech
solution that rewrote his genetic
material to anyone who tested Terry's
blood his DNA was composed of Mary
McGinnis and Bruce Wayne now in truth
this bit of information was a surprise
to some but only small and that it
seemed a natural progression to have
Terry become the son of Bruce the reason
for this was that as a man who it
emotionally disses himself on the rest
of the world it seems strange that he
was suddenly turncoat and become a
father figure to a boy he hardly knew
the downside of this revelation was that
it came as a throw in to wrap up the
cancelled series and never allow Tim
Dini or Burnett to flesh out the
characters any further now the reason
why I brought up this discussion on
Terry's heritage is that while as comic
book appearances ended with the end of
Batman Beyond vol 2 when DC initiated
their line wide reboot in 2011 with the
new 52 the Terry McGinnis was brought
back under the Batman Beyond brand under
the writing of Adam Beechen who had also
drawn the series with contributions from
Ryan Benjamin covered in a March 2010
blog by DC's editorial team because a
new 52 was designed to bring in new
readers who felt alienated by the
massive backlog of DC related content
and the knowledge necessary to
understand everything that was going on
with different creators being offered
the opportunity to revamp or reintroduce
existing and previously canceled
publications to this end B gen was
approached by DC co-publisher Dan DiDio
for the purpose of testing the waters to
see if an interest remain in seeing
Terry McGinnis return to the DC comic
landscape appearing within the pages of
Superman Batman annual number four in
the story a time beyond hope from August
2010 exactly one year before the launch
of the new 52 because a Superman Batman
line of comics allowed for one shots and
multi-part stories dealing with the
escapades of Bruce Wayne and Clark
outside of the official DC timeline the
appearance of Terry acting as Batman in
this story allowed DC to experiment with
fan reception without committing to an
ongoing series at the start of the new
52 written by Paul Levitz the story took
a more adult-oriented standpoint than
previous Batman Beyond comics by having
Lex Luthor seize control of Metropolis
infecting the city citizens with
kryptonite and keeping Superman away
centering on Terry McGinnis
investigating why Gotham was
experiencing a sudden influx of
criminals from metropolis the store
revealed that despite being unable to
remain in the city for any length of
time Superman had been jumping in and
out too fast to be seen but imprisoning
various criminals within the Phantom
Zone coming together alongside Clark in
his efforts to track down and defeat
Luthor once Lex was in prison in the
Phantom Zone for eternity Superman
departed earth leaving Terry behind to
act as jailer for those trapped in the
Phantom Zone now using this as a
jumping-off platform due to fans being
excited to see Terry return even if only
for the sake of nostalgia in the next
few weeks
under writer Adam beech in DC launched
Batman Beyond vol 3 as a six-part
miniseries while the overarching villain
of the miniseries was revealed to be
hush an enemy of Bruce Wayne who had
escaped imprisonment and sought to kill
Bruce the purpose behind the miniseries
was to actually retcon the relationship
between Terry and Bruce by removing the
storyline of Amanda Waller altering the
DNA of Terry's biological father Warren
while fans didn't object to this due to
the fact that the plotline seemed to
have been something the series didn't
need anyway when the new 52 was
officially launched in August of 2011 DC
maintained the idea of Terry being an
adoptive son of Bruce instead of
biological however the success of the
Batman Beyond line under Adam beech it
was extremely short-lived and that the
title only lasted eight issues before
being cancelled due to poor sales were
some contributed this to the
inconsistent art and others pointed to
the idea that Batman Beyond was not
actually as popular as fans made it out
to be the series was rolled over into a
digital only line of comics and expanded
to include justice Lee Beyond and
Superman Beyond creating a universe
separate from the main new 52 continuity
similar to the injustice series whether
we've allowed DC to save money on
distribution and release more comics on
a longer time scale the titles continue
to prove unsuccessful with Superman
Beyond Justice League Beyond and Batman
Beyond all being canceled in June of
2013 now following this and viewing the
titles failure as being due to the fact
that the Batman Beyond related titles
had existed outside of the new 52 in May
of 2014
underwriters Brian Azzarello Jeff Lemire
Dan Jergens and Keith Giffen DC
initiated a ten-part story future's end
that's a way to roll Batman Beyond over
into the new 52 continuity with Terry
McGinnis
slated to be replaced by Tim Drake as
well as lead into the events of
convergence taking place 35 years in the
future and centering on the
transformation of Earth's key
into cyborgs my brother I a sentient
satellite developed in part by Bruce
Wayne and designed a monitor superhero
activity Terry McGinnis had jumped into
the past in an effort to halt the
development of brother AI and prevent
the conversion of humans to cyborgs
arriving five years later than he
intended to because a conversion process
was already underway the remainder of
the story saw Terry McGinnis teaming up
with Tim Drake to defeat weather-eye
before the conversion of Heroes to
cyborgs could continue because a
conclusion of the story saw Terry
McGinnis dying in June of 2015 this
series was relaunched as vol 6 under the
writing of Dan Jergens placing Tim Drake
in the title role and Dick Grayson
replacing Bruce Wayne and truth the
change-up left the Batman Beyond
community split where altered fans
wanted to see Terry McGinnis return
since he was viewed as the definitive
version of the character since he was
the only one to ever operate as Batman
Beyond up until the relaunch newer fans
were growing tired of seeing DC
rebranded the new 52 as a new era of
comics while holding onto old ideologies
during an interview with DC Comics comm
prior to the series release liner Dan
Jorgensen stated the futures and could
best be summed up as establishing Terry
McGinnis as someone who existed in the
future of the new 52 continuity with a
series ending with Harry being replaced
by Tim Drake with the new Batman Beyond
would remain as part of the new 52
because it took place in the future of
the continuity the problem faced by fans
was that there should have been some
reference to present events within the
pages of the Batman Beyond comics the
fact that this did not happen
left readers feeling the series was part
of the new 52 in name only something
that was compounded on following the
events of convergence going into DC U
and the mantra of story over continuity
so with executive editor Jeff jobs at DC
announcing the DC rebirth event during
WonderCon of 2016 it was officially
announced oh the Batman Beyond line
would be relaunched and see the return
of Terry McGinnis now for those of you
who are unfamiliar with DC rebirth or
not being keeping up with the news as
it's been released one of the biggest
criticisms of the new 52 was that it
completely wiped away decades of
character development for the sake of
providing a fresh starting off point
while DC itself had been tight-lipped
about admitting this issue or
acknowledging its legitimacy and the
face of Marvel Secret Wars event the
launch of the marvel prime universe and
declining sales DC announced rebirth as
a way to reset some of their characters
and teams to their pre new 52 status in
the hopes of having a best of both
worlds continuity while most of these
changes won't be clearly known until the
rebirth of n actually starts in June of
questions reign among fans as to how
Terry will return despite having died at
the conclusion of future's end with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end and let me know how you
guys feel about Batman Beyond do you
love him do you not really care I'm kind
of curious and I will catch you guys
later peace
we
you